Speaker 1: One of the questions that we've
been asking and that has been increasingly
answered has been who knew? And how widespread
was the foreknowledge that regardless of the
2020 election results failed, former President
Donald Trump was going to declare victory?
Well, over time, we've learned that more and
more people were aware that this was Donald
Trump's plan. Regardless of the outcome. We've
heard now that a a drunken Rudy jewel allegedly
drunk and Rudy Giuliani was suggesting that
he'd do it on election night. But even earlier
than that, in late October, we now have leaked
audio of former Trump adviser and propagandist
Stephen Bannon, saying the plan is to say
that he won. He might not have won, but the
plan is to say that he won. And this is an
explosive new report from Mother Jones. Leaked
audio before Election Day. Bannon said Trump
plan to falsely claim victory. Bannon, who
at that point was no longer officially working
for Trump, knew the plan. If Bannon knew it,
how many people working for Trump knew it?
It's very clear that this was obviously the
plan that they had. That's our strategy. He's
going to declare himself a winner. We actually
have the leaked audio. Let's take a look at
it.
Speaker 5: The Democrats dump more of our
people, vote early, they count their voting
mail. And so they're going to have a natural
disadvantage in Trump's going to take advantage
if that's our strategy. He's Clarence Thomas
winner. So when you wake up Wednesday morning,
it's going to be a firestorm.
Speaker 1: Now, they had the same information
we had back in, what, July, August, September
of 2020. I was telling you, I was telling
everybody there's going to be this red mirage.
We expect that for a number of different reasons,
including that Democrats seem more poised
and more likely to vote by mail, that the
early results may favor Trump more than the
eventual results, and that over the course
of the evening and depending on which state,
because some states stop counting at 10 p.m.
or 11 p.m. and then start up again the next
day over the course of the night or the next
day, Joe Biden was going to gain momentum.
We knew that. They knew that as well. Bannon
admits it here. He says there's going to be
the situation where the the voting trends
are going to favor Trump early. So Trump's
just going to go out there and declare victory.
Let's listen to a little bit of that again,
because it's so critical and that will keep
going early.
Speaker 5: They count their vote in mail and
so they're going to have a natural disadvantage
in trust to take advantage of. That's our
strength. He's got a sense of winner. So when
you wake up Wednesday morning, it's going
to be a firestorm. Going to have a team from
crazy, the media crazy.
Speaker 1: Now Antifa, the Antifa did nothing
and Antifa was a non-factor. He's wrong about
that.
Speaker 5: Courts are crazy and Trump's really
sitting there. Mark, between that you lose,
right? I'm the mayor, I'm the king. And he'll
be all over him. He'll be gone. Where's Hunter?
Is Hunter on a crack pipe? I mean, now he'll
be, because then it doesn't matter. Remember,
here's the thing. After that, Trump never
has to go to a voter again. He's going to
fire Wray, the FBI director, for the scene,
as if you have it. He's never going to he's
he's done his last election. Oh, he's going
to be off the chase. We freeze also also in
Kroger. If Trump is losing by ten, 11:00 at
night, it's going to be even crazier, you
know, because he's gonna sit right there,
say they stolen.
Speaker 1: And that's exactly what he.
Speaker 5: Did. Yeah, I agree. I'm directing
the attorney general to shut down all ballot
places, all 50 states. It's going to be. No,
he's not going out easier. Trump and Biden
is winning. Trump is going to do some crazy
shit.
Speaker 1: And that is exactly what happened.
So this is a leak. The leak is relevant. Why?
Because it tells us that even people no longer
in Trump's inner circle knew what the plan
was. Bannon was not working for Trump at that
point, and he knew exactly what the plan was.
And he was right. That's from that's from
the end of October 2020, and that's exactly
what happened. So it is a leak. But from what
Donald Trump said publicly, it was clear since
the summer of 2020 that he was going to claim
to be the winner. One way or another. He was
saying, oh, this vote by mail stuff is all
fraud. I mean, Trump voted by mail, sure.
But that's Trump. Other people are committing
fraud by voting by mail. Democrats, black
people. So it was abundantly clear that this
was the plan and Bannon knew it. And so the
concerted effort to carry this out as the
strategy was not a particularly closely held
secret. Bannon had, of course, more specific
knowledge. Bannon knew, Oh, well, he's going
to try to shut down ballots. Trump tried to
seize voting machines and do all these different
things. But even from what Trump said publicly,
and even from when Trump was asked, Will you
accept the results if they say that Biden
won? And he said, Well, I'd have to see what
went on first. This was actually you know,
what's even more interesting is this was the
plan for the 2016 election as well. In 2016,
Trump thought he was going to lose to Hillary
and he was going to say, Oh, she won because
of fraud and whatever. But Trump's going to
move on with his life and go back to being
businessman. Trump In fact, if you really
want to be historically accurate, Trump started
with some of the election can't be trusted
stuff in 2012, claiming that Barack Obama's
victory over Mitt Romney was, you know, there
were problems with the Electoral College and
all sorts of different things. Trump wasn't
personally involved then in 20, remember in
2016 when Trump won in the Electoral College
but lost the popular vote? He continues to
say to this day that he actually defeated
Hillary Clinton in the popular vote as well.
And remember, the claims of there were people
from Massachusetts brought in busses to New
Hampshire to help her. How people from Massachusetts
would be registered to vote in New Hampshire
continues to be beyond me. It's never been
answered. But Trump still hasn't admitted
that the popular vote results of 2016 were
accurate. So Trump was going to do this in
2016. He just so happened to win electorally.
And then of course he did it in 2020 and he
told us that he was going to do it. So stunning
stuff that it seems everybody knew that this
was the plan. And now we have Steve Bannon
on the record due to this leak saying this
was the plan all along